We are now ready to define the notion
of the Hidden Markov Model,
and to do this, we will turn the dealer
into a machine with k hidden states.
This machine will proceed
in a sequence of steps,
and, for example,
in the case of coin flipping, these
hidden states will correspond
to fair or biased coins.
At each step, the machine emits one
of the symbols from the alphabet.
In the case of coin flipping, the symbols
the machine will emits will be heads or
tails, of course.
And, while in a certain state,
the machine makes two decisions:
"Which symbol will I emit?"
(this is the first question
it has to answer),
and "Which hidden state
will I move to next?"
(this is the second question
it has to answer).
And it uses probabilistic arguments
to make these two decisions.
Now, why is the word "hidden"
in the "Hidden Markov Model"?
An observer can see
the emitted symbol of an HMM
but doesn't know which state the machine
was in when it emitted this hidden symbol,
and the goal is to infer the most
likely sequence of hidden states
of an HMM based on the sequence
of emitted symbols.
Formally, the Hidden Markov Model is
defined by the set of the following
four objects.
First, an alphabet of emitted symbols.
Second, a set of hidden states of the HMM.
In the case of the crooked casino,
an alphabet of emitted symbols
will be heads or tails;
a set of hidden states will be
fair or biased coin.
Next, a matrix of
transition probabilities,
which describes the probability of
moving from state l to state k.
In our example of the crooked casino,
this is the matrix.
For example, the probability of moving
from state F to state F is 0.9,
but, the probability of moving from
state F to state B will be 0.1
because the probability of
switching coins is 0.1.
And finally, the Hidden Markov
Model is described by matrix of
emission probabilities that describes
the probability of emitting symbol b
when the HMM is in state k.
For example, for the crooked casino,
this matrix is shown on the slide.
The probability of emitting heads
from the fair state is 0.5,
but the probability of emitting
heads from the biased state is 0.75.
We will represent HMMs by HMM diagrams.
In the case of crooked casino,
our HMM has two states: F and B,
and there are all possible
transitions between these states,
and these transitions are described by
the transition probability matrix.
This HMM emits two symbols: H and T,
and the probability of
emitting these symbols
is described by the emission
probability matrix.
To study Hidden Markov Models, we will
define the notion of a hidden path.
The hidden path is a sequence of
states that the HMM passes through,
and we will denote it as:
pi = pi1 pi2 ... piN
We will also define the
probability of (x,pi), aka Pr(x,pi)
which is the probability that an HMM
follows the hidden path pi and
emits the string x.
In this slide, you see
an example of string x
and hidden path pi.
Our goal is to compute Pr(x,pi).
Note that if we sum up probabilities of
(x,pi) through all possible strings x
and through all possible paths P,
the result will be, of course, 1.
So there are how many
sums times sums?
It is 2^n choices of x
multiplied by 2^n choices of pi.
To compute Pr(x,pi),
we will need to introduce
one more notion, which is the
probability of x given pi, aka Pr(x|pi).
Pr(x|pi) is the conditional
probability that an HMM
emits the string x after
following the hidden path pi.
Please note that, in this
case, the sum through all possible
emitted strings x of Pr(x|pi)
is equal to 1.
Please notice the difference
between these two sums.
The sum on the top is the sum of
2^n choices of x multiplied by
2^n choices of pi,
while the sum on the bottom is the sum
of 2^n corresponding to
all possible emitted strings x.
We are now ready to compute
the probability that an HMM
follows the hidden path pi and
emits the string x.
To compute it, we need to define the
notion of probability of xi given pi_i,
which is the probability that symbol
xi was emitted from the state pi_i.
And this probability of course is equal to
the entry of the emission probability
matrix that corresponds to emitting
symbol xi from the state pi_i.
Well, let's compute these probabilities.
For the first column,
we have fair state emitting tails,
which is, of course, 1/2,
then fair state emitting heads,
which is, again, 1/2,
fair state emitting tails, 1/2,
and now biased state emitting heads,
which is 3/4.
If we continue like this,
we will find out all these probabilities.
Another thing that we need to compute to
find Pr(x,pi) is the
probability of transitioning
from the state pi_i to
the state pi_(i+1),
Which is simply the transition
probability from the state pi_i to
the state pi_(i+1).
Let's start computing those probabilities.
Well, at a first step, we transition
from fair state to fair state,
with probability 0.9.
At the next step, again from fair
state to fair state, again 0.9.
But at the next step, we transition
from fair state to bias state,
which has probability 0.1.
We'll continue this way,
and in this way, we will
compute all these values.
We forgot about just one value,
which is: What is
the probability that our HMM
was in the fair or
biased state in the first moment?
Now let's assume that
in the initial moment,
HMM was equally likely to be either
in the fair state or the biased state.
That's why we add this term 0.5.
So after we filled this row,
we know that the probability of pi,
the probability that HMM will
go through path pi,
will simply be the product of
the corresponding transition probabilities.
And what is, after we computed
these values, Pr(pi) and Pr(x|pi),
we can compute Pr(x,pi),
which is simply the product of all these
small probabilities that we computed;
equal to Pr(x|pi) * Pr(pi).
So the problem of computing Pr(x,pi)
has been reduced to two problems.
The first problem is how to
compute Pr(pi),
and the second problem is how
to compute the probability of an
emitted string given a hidden path,
and this is the problem of
computing Pr(x|pi).
And we know now how to
solve both these problems.